[Musique]
cette année c'est le 100e anniversaire
du massacre acial de tout ça ou ce qu'on
appelait le black wall street
la communauté noire alors la plus riche
des etats-unis a été détruite par des
foules sanctionné par l'état ces
événements sont aujourd'hui considéré
comme l'un des pires actes de violences
raciales de l'histoire du 20e siècle aux
états unis et sont certainement
emblématique des trois fléaux évoqués
par martin luther king junior le racisme
l'exploitation économique et le
militarisme depuis atlanta me rejoint la
fille de martin luther king junior et
actuelle présidente du centre martin
luther king junior pour le changement
social non violent bernis merci beaucoup
de participer à cette émission c'était
il me semble 28 juillet 1960 que votre
père est allé à tous à la première
église baptiste de greenwood avenue
pourquoi selon vous est-ce que c'est
seulement maintenant 100 ans plus tard
que le monde apprend l'existence de ce
black hole street
historiquement comme c'est lié aux
incidences mais aussi aux contributions
de la fois les ricains cela elle était
d'une certaine manière cachée et mis
sous le tapis fait c'est seulement ces
dernières années ils sont à émerger
cette force de jeunes gens réclament ont
vraiment plus de liberté dans notre
société ça plus d'honnêteté à noter que
ces choses-là ont commencé à remonter à
la surface
je pense que c'est une farce que
d'apprendre toute cette histoire je veux
dire certains d'entre nous la connaissez
déjà mais il s'agit désormais d'une
prise de conscience sur les questions
raciales
si elle n'avait pas eu lieu auparavant
parce qu'il me semble utile qui n'en
avions pas fait un problème récurrent de
génération en génération
pour certains qui croient au rêve
américain cela peut être perturbant
parce que cela fait comprendre que même
si les afro américains deviennent
entrepreneurs font des affaires
eh bien on les tue on les assassine on
met feu à leur maison à leur business
c'est la raison pour laquelle mon père a
été assassiné
c'est parce qu'il a commencé à parler de
la justice économique et de la manière
dont le militarisme nuisait à la guerre
contre la pauvreté c'est là qu'il est
devenu une menace pour la nation pour
l'establishment pour le statu quo en fin
de compte ce n'est pas seulement aux
états unis mais dans le monde entier
s'il y a un grave problème avec les
personnes noires
quel que soit le pays où on se trouve
il faut s'attaquer au problème de faces
b
c'est pourquoi avons-nous créé ces
systèmes et structures ou devrais je
dire pourquoi les gens ont-ils besoin de
discriminer d'autres gens pour se sentir
important puissant et garder le pouvoir
à m c'est ce qui se passe dans ce monde
sait ce qu'est le racisme la croyance
qu'il y a des races des gens supérieures
et inférieures et surtout que les noirs
sont à fire nous devons donc continuer
nous n'arrêterons pas de parler de
suprématie sme des blancs et du besoin
de le détruire de le faire disparaître
du besoin de créer enfin des systèmes et
des structures plus équitable dans notre
pays quand tu vas y donnerons nous avons
souvent parlé dans cette émission du
principe de diviser pour mieux régner
je pense que la rédactrice de l'émission
n'aura rien à redire si je mentionne
qu'il ya un certain nombre d'années je
me suis disputé avec elle concernant les
différents héritages de malcom x et de
martin luther king junior
comme vous venez de le dire votre père
parlait du militarisme et c'est
peut-être pourquoi il a été assassiné
d'où vient cette idée qu'il faut choisir
son camp entre malcom x et votre père
[Musique]
séné dans le mouvement il y avait des
gens qui croyaient clairement que mon
père était passif que malcolm étaient
plus agressifs et ils ont fait un
problème ça a été surtout une question
de génération c'est arrivé alors que mon
père prenait de l'âge n'était pas si
vieux que ça il n'avait que 39 ans quand
on l'a tuée mais dans les années 60
quand il est entré dans la trentaine ce
qui avait 18 ans qui faisait des études
et cetera était très déçu par l'absence
de progrès importants surtout sur le
plan économique comme malcolm était plus
proche de chicago
les gens avaient tendance à soutenir son
message en bas ça ce qu'il parlait
d'auto émancipation cela a attiré plus
la jeune génération
c'est là que les médias ont commencé à
les opposer et malcom lui-même a dit des
choses qui critiquait directement la non
violence
[Musique]
donc les gens ont commencé à les
considérer comme diamétralement opposées
nous savons tous que en 1965 je crois
malcolm et aller à la mecque et ça a été
un tournant dans sa manière de percevoir
la race blanche il a vu à la mecque des
gens avec des yeux bleus avec la peau
blanche qui priaient allah avec lui et
ça a changé sa vision des personnes
blanches en général quand il est revenu
lui et mon père ils se sont croisés
brièvement je crois qu'ils avaient fait
le voyage en 1964 ils se sont donc
croiser à la signature du civil right
act et je pense qu'il ya eu des peurs
que les deux puissent s'unir et soudain
malcolm 10
et en 1965 je ne pense pas que quiconque
qui a entendu le discours de la du
vietnam le moment de briser le silence
puisse penser que ce n'était pas radical
vous avez dit que les gens ne se
souvenait peut-être pas aussi bien de
votre mère qu'il le faudrait est ce que
le fait que les gens ne connaissais pas
très bien le discours sur le vietnam à
aider votre mère a mené cette campagne
ma mère était une militante pacifiste
avant de rencontrer mon père chinoise
c'est principalement elle même s'il ya
eu d'autres personnes mais elle était la
principale qui l'a encouragée à
s'exprimer ouvertement contre la guerre
du vietnam en public elle a dit martin
nous avons besoin de ta voix dans le
mouvement pour la paix nous avons besoin
de ton autorité morale shanxi
je pense que ses efforts pour le
persuader sont en fin de compte ce qui
lui a donné la force de le faire ce
n'est pas qu'il n'en avait pas le
courage
c'était un pari ce qu'est pour lui
beaucoup de ses amis l'ont trahi
beaucoup de membres du mouvement des
droits civiques l'on tape à quai les
fonds de la sclc l'organisation dont il
était président qu'il dirige et qui
guidait le mouvement s'épuiser elle sort
grâce à sa passion à sa compréhension de
l'importance qu'avait ses paroles ses
discours à elle a commencé avant son
assassinat à chercher des moyens de
conserver ses papiers elle se rendait
compte que les générations futures
aurait besoin de comprendre son travail
sa doctrine à 100
finalement quand il a été assassiné elle
a prié elle a senti que dieu lui disais
de créer ce centre le centre martin
luther king junior pour le changement
social non violent avec les écrits de
martin luther king junior comme
fondation
elle a voyagé autour du monde après
l'assassinât avec son livre ma vie avec
martin luther king elle a voyagé
puis elle est revenue aux états unis
parce qu'elle voulait que les gens
apprennent le pur message et la doctrine
de martin luther king junior ainsi a
commencé sa croisade pour développer ce
que certains appellent la plus grande
marque de changement social dans le
monde
elle a été l'architecte de l'héritage de
martin luther king
ensuite la commencer à discuter avec les
gouverneurs les maires les commissaires
aux états unis pour lancer un jour férié
en l'honneur de king en janvier et son
anniversaire est un jour férié
quand ce jour est devenu férié en 1983
quand la loi a été signée dans beaucoup
d'états et de ville cette journée était
déjà célébré donc toute sa vie a été
consacrée au travail qu'il faisait
elle a toujours senti que les paroles et
la doctrine de martin luther king junior
serait essentiel pour les futures
générations dans leur objectif de créer
un monde équitable et pacifique
je pense qu'elle a accompli seul un
énorme travail
bien sûr on l'aider mais pour une
personne seule qu'on a privé de son mari
d'une manière aussi brutale
elle a décidé de canaliser toute cette
douleur dans la réalisation d'un
objectif
voilà pourquoi nous avons cette icône
qui est martin luther king junior 6
coretta scott qu'il n'avait pas fait
tout ce qu'elle a fait je pense vraiment
que nous n'aurions pas cette
conversation aujourd'hui parce que
c'était une partie d'elle au lieu de se
dire bon j'ai perdu mon mari
qu'est ce que je vais faire maintenant
elle s'est dit d'accord j'ai perdu mon
mari mais nous étions partenaires dans
ce travail en commun
je dois continuer d'aller de l'avant et
m'assurer que tout ce que nous avons
défendu tout ce qu'il nous a appris et
dont il était l'incarnation continue
c'est ce qu'elle a fait et max motiver
certains estiment que le discours sur le
vietnam inspirer énormément de militants
pacifistes pour mettre fin à la guerre
je ne sais pas combien de millions de
vies ont pu être sauvées grâce au
retrait du vietnam et de l'asie du sud
est
pensez vous que beaucoup d'américains le
savent que pensez vous du fait que c'est
à cause de ce discours du fait qu'ils
soient entrés dans le débat sur les
affaires étrangères que votre père a été
tué je ne pense pas que ce soit
seulement parce qu'il a pris position
contre la guerre mais parce qu'il a liés
à l'économie disant qu ont détourné des
fonds pour ôter des vies plutôt que
d'investir ces fonds dans
l'enrichissement et l'amélioration de la
vie des gens le président johnson a
appelé à mener une guerre contre la
pauvreté mais rien ne se produisait et
on voyait ses soldats noirs allaient
lutter côte à côte pour la liberté de la
mairie mais il revenait et se retrouver
dans leurs communautés ségrégué il a
commencé à mettre en lumière cette
incohérence
c'est devenu un problème pour la nation
et les structures de pouvoir
est ce un problème de faire ce lien
aujourd'hui quelque chose oui si vous
faites ce lien aujourd'hui des gens vont
estimer que vous n'êtes pas patriote
très peu de gens font ce lien si on le
fait maintenant
au delà même de la guerre parlons de ce
qui se passe dans le monde et surtout ce
qui se passe dans notre pays de la
violence politique
on espère beaucoup de forces de l'ordre
sont militarisé on regarde comment ils
sont armés en quand ils sortent dans les
rues pour faire face aux manifestants
c'est comme une vraie guerre
il s'agit dans beaucoup de cas de
manifestation pacifique où les gens font
face à des policiers militarisé m 100 m
a pu pendant lequel les gens
de plus en plus mais je pense que ce
qu'ils ne font pas c'est se dire écoutez
notre industrie militaire reçoit à peu
près 52 cents par dollar taxi et
seulement 200 sont investis dans la
santé publique
ok 200 dans la santé et le bien-être et
200 au moins dans l'éducation est lé
sens nous devons donc faire face à ce
problème dans notre pays parce que nous
sommes plus focalisés sur notre
puissance que sur notre moralité c'est
de cela que parle et mon père l'amérique
a besoin de se repentir de commencer une
révolution de valeur mouche mais ce sont
les gens et pas les objets qui doivent
être au coeur parce que ces guerres si
on retire le voile porte sur le contrôle
et les ressources
c'est ce qui lui a créé des problèmes
bernice king nous allons revenir après
une courte pause pour continuer cet
entretien
[Musique]
de retour pour l'interview de la fille
du révérend martin luther king junior
bernice king
cent ans après le massacre raciale de
tout ça les néolibéraux pourrais vous
dire que les choses ont beaucoup changé
depuis les jours votre père mener son
combat
après tout le policier derek chauvin a
été condamné pour le meurtre de george
floyd parce que chez il a saisi le
tribunal avec une demande de
condamnation avec sursis et mise à
l'épreuve
arguant qu'il n'était que le fruit d'un
système brisé qu'il pourrait être utile
à la communauté
que pensez vous de cette demande
étant donné que le ministère public
insiste sur 30 ans de prison tout avocat
doit défendre son client
je ne suis pas fâché contre lui mais ce
n'est pas réaliste je ne pense pas que
les juges répondront positivement à sa
demande
je ne veux même pas dépenser de
l'énergie sur ce sujet parce que cela
n'en vaut pas la peine
il mérite la plus grande punition
possible par ce beau il a ôté la vie à
un être humain il l'a fait de manière
cynique sans remords un seul instant ce
n'est qu'une personne mais même s'il a
été reconnu coupable et quelle que soit
la punition il y a tout un système cela
se produit encore et encore
il y à d'autres vidéos qui ont été
publiées avant celle de georges floyd et
il y a des choses qui se passent après
george de floyd à 100 nous voyons que
oui les choses ont changé on ne peut pas
dire qu'après tout ce que mon père a
fait dans sa vie rien n'a changé j'ai
nommé russe et bien sûr que des choses
ont changé
nous avons vu une augmentation
importante du nombre d'élus noire des
afro américains qui font maintenant
partie de la classe moyenne
il y à quelques riches bien pu provoquer
il y a des gens qui peuvent forger de
vrais liens d'amitié entre toutes les
races alors que c'était très dangereux
surtout dans le sud dans les années 50
de plus en plus d'américains noir vont à
l'université les choses de cette nature
mais en fin de compte comme disait mon
père en 1965 après le voting rights act
le vrai défi maintenant et c'est d'aller
vers une vraie égalité
c'est là que les gens commencent à se
recroqueviller se retirer s'excuser et
c'est ce que nous voyons maintenant dans
notre pays dépend de ma les gens n'ont
pas envie de payer le prix suprême pour
vaincre d'une égalité raciale à m
pourtant on nous aurons y faire face et
à en payer le prix
à faire des sacrifices dans ce pays nv
ce match et elle tient jusqu'à ce que la
majorité de l'amérique au sens le plus
large soit vraiment attaché au
démantèlement du racisme nous allons
tout simplement continuer la lutte
nous n'accepterons pas les systèmes et
les structures les pratiques et les
politiques qui continuent de faire en
sorte chez les noirs soient toujours les
derniers on ne peut pas laisser cela se
produire
je voudrais revenir dans quelques
instants sur les appels aux réparations
et à la campagne be love
mais une autre chose qui a changé selon
certains libéraux c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de noirs en position de
pouvoir ces dernières années que voulait
dire votre père quand il soulignait à
l'époque
la majorité des leaders politiques noirs
n'accède pas au pouvoir grâce à un
soutien de masse la plupart sont choisis
par les blancs élevé par les blancs
cette époque est elle révolue où il ya
toujours des gens à un certain degré de
pouvoir qui ne sont pas fidèles aux
valeurs de martin luther king junior
on appelle cela du toqué misme faire en
sorte qu'il y une personne qui
représente un groupe particulier que
nous appelons minorité dans notre pays
c'est du toc et nice mme cela arrive de
temps en temps dans notre pays de
manière différente
si on regarde les conseils
d'administration les pdg des 500
entreprises de fortune
ce sont majoritairement des hommes
blancs à elle il y a toujours cette peur
d'ouvrir la porte elle de faire en sorte
qu'on fasse monter d'autres gens pour
qu'ils y est l'équité c'est un long
chemin à parcourir je pense qu'il ya une
grande peur chez les hommes blancs en
amérique d'être remplacé d'être écartée
d'espoir voilà pourquoi il ya un tel
rejet dans ce pays gratuit mais nous
avons néanmoins la responsabilité en
cherchant un moyen de progresser de ne
pas déboucher sur des résultats qui
seraient similaires à ceux du passé mais
avec une situation où cette fois ce sont
les hommes blancs qui seraient laissés
en arrière on ne peut pas faire ça nous
devons créer une communauté d'amour où
les talents de tout le monde serait
respectée on n'en tiendrai compte où il
y aurait équité justice
partage tout ce genre de choses mais
encore une fois cela ne se produira pas
avant que nous ne changions notre
système de valeurs
mon père a était prophétique en nous
encourageant en 1967
dans son livre where do we go from au
premier multi à commencer rapidement le
passage d'une société centrée sur les
objets à une société centrée sur les
individus dans le cadre d'une révolution
de valeur il disait également que nous
devrions faire bouger nos allégeances de
manière à cesser d'être exclusif
autrement dit ne pas être orientés par
groupe ne pas conserver sa loyauté
uniquement envers le groupe dans ton
fait partie que ce soit un groupe
national racial ou religieux
il faut être plus de cuménique il faut
être loyal envers l'humanité avant tout
vu melle et à moins que nous arrivions à
ce système de valeurs où nous aurons
toujours cela en tête en mettant en
oeuvre nos politiques en mettant en
place des pratiques et en s'engageant
les uns envers les autres
je pense qu'on finira toujours avec le
même résultat
les noires resteront toujours sur le
banc de touche
les métis aussi on ne fera que des pas
insignifiant le tranquillisants qu'est
la demi mesure
c'est ce qu'il disait mais les
américains les britanniques étaient
peut-être sur le point d'avoir des lois
d'identification faciale des électeurs
et votre fondation prône la non-violence
comment pouvez vous penser à des
changements démocratiques si cette
oppression des électeurs reprend
apparemment da dynamique aux états unis
et même ici oui c'est le rejet dont je
viens de parler une fois qu'un pas et
fait en avant il y a toujours cette
réaction qui vous pousse à faire deux
pas en arrière
quant à la dynamique nous devons
continuer à aller de l'avant a organisé
à mobiliser à penser des stratégies
c'est ce que martin luther king ne
faisait il a connu des échecs
il a dû reculer mais il fallait se
reprendre le défi que nous avons dans ce
pays c'est que les gens de bonne volonté
doivent trouver un moyen de se
coordonner de collaborer et d'avancer
ensemble pour régler ces problèmes d'eau
pression des électeurs
j'essaie de ne pas me mêler de tout les
différents problèmes comme le scrutin le
dimanche où les urnes électorales etc
tout cela est important mais l'essentiel
dans ces parties de la législation ce
sont les dispositions qui autorise le
gouverneur ou même l'état à venir et
privés de leur pouvoir les commissions
électorales locales et prendre des
décisions
cela veut dire qu'ils peuvent changer le
cours d'une élection
en gros c'est dangereux
quel que soit le parti auquel vous à
berrer parce que cela peut donner lieu à
des inégalités à des fraudes etc
c'est ce qui devrait inquiéter
c'est pourquoi tant de poursuites
judiciaires ont été intentés contre
beaucoup de ces éléments de la
législation voilà pourquoi il est
important de focaliser notre attention
pour faire passer cette législation
fédérale
le john lewis voting rights act et le
fort des people au sénat beaucoup de
gens appellent le président et la
vice-présidente kamala harris à prendre
leurs responsabilités et à leur demande
à mettre fin à l'obstruction
parlementaire parce que c'est le corps
et l'âme de la démocratie voter c'est ce
qui fait de nous une communauté ils ont
des expériences controversé avec kamal a
comme ancien procureur de californie
avait comme pratique l'incarcération de
masse et enfin vous appelez les
anciennes puissances coloniales d'europe
de l'ouest a procédé à des réparations
pour ce que les gouvernements ont fait
subir pendant des siècles aux gens de
couleur pensez vous que cela va dans le
sens de ce que votre père disait de la
dimension cruciale de l'économie
il avait dit pendant la marche pour
l'emploi qu'abraham lincoln avait lu
karl marx est il si t'es ok ici et pablo
neruda le célèbre poète communiste
l'économie est elle cruciale dans tout
cela et quelles ont été vos succès dans
cet appel aux réparations enesco c'est
un combat beaucoup de gens ont appelé à
cela beaucoup de gens ont témoigné au
capitole en effet mon père disait si
vous avez fait quelque chose contre des
peuples
à l'époque pendant son temps il faut
revenir en arrière et faire quelque
chose pour ces peuples à il n'utilisait
pas directement le mot réparation mais
il disait qu'il devait y avoir une forme
de réparation 1 et que cela n'a rien
coûté à notre pays d'abolir la
ségrégation pas un centime
et pourtant il y a une grande dette
qu'il a mentionné dans son discours i
have a dream à la communauté noire pour
les années d'exploitation de notre
travail et les moyens terrible inhumain
d'obtenir la force de travail et de
s'enrichir dans ce pays via l' esclavage
qui est tout ce dont on parle on peut
vaquer à nos affaires mais il continue
de nous détruire et de prendre des
choses
nous leur faisons rien nous sommes
tombés mais une dette c'est une dette
quand on a des dettes sur son bilan
comptable on doit les payer
c'est le moment pour les nations où
cette exploitation et lieu de payer la
dette aux descendants de ceux qui ont
été exploitées marginalisés tuer ou qui
ont fait l'objet d'un traitement
inhumain dans ce monde
bernice king merci
[Musique]